[Musique]
ils sont chaque année des dizaines à
s'engager sur ces chantiers d'été tous
bénévoles venus du monde entier
expérimenté ou totalement novice leur
objectif est le même
sauvegarder notre patrimoine nous avons
suivi alexandra passionné d'archéologie
depuis l'enfance jade étudiante en
histoire de l'art et futurs
restauratrice abbas réfugiés iraniens
arrivé en france l'année dernière il est
à peine 7 heures début d'une journée de
chantier pour alexandra et ses collègues
leur mission consolider les ruines de ce
site archéologique vieux de 4300 ans
vous allez me préparer donc une double
avec dont 4 de sable jaune et 4 de sable
rouge
vous allez ma corpore à tout ça info et
demie de show blanche et 1/2 saut de
l'autre choc nous a enlevé
alexandra et étudiantes et si elle a
décidé de passer ses vacances les mains
dans la chaux c'est surtout pour la vie
en collectivité
les rencontres on est plein de deux
jeunes ou moins jeunes à venir ici de
pays différents
donc c'est pour rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes de nouvelles cultures
par exemple un dans notre groupe il ya
une personne qui vient d'afghanistan une
autre du nigeria soudan maroc
donc c'est assez incroyable de tous
déjeuner ensemble à discuter de comment
on voit le monde ce que nous on a appris
abbas lui a fui son pays d'origine
l'iran et est arrivé en france il ya un
an malgré la barrière de la langue
il cherche aussi les rencontres pour
mieux s'intégrer
son rêve c'est de devenir mécanicien
alors avant de réparer un jour des
véhicules il renforce l'étanchéité de
cette péniche moyen pour lui de garder
la tête hors de l'eau
je voulais avoir de l'expérience voir
comment on travaille ici en france je
trouve que c'est très intéressant pour
moi c'est encore mieux que ce que
j'espérais c'est la première fois qu'ils
participent à un chantier d'été tout
comme alexandra d'éclat mortier
approprié qu'il est trop raide
automatiquement quatre ans la brusque
panique
sinon ce procès à venir ici était pour
elle une évidence
l'archéologie c'est sa passion depuis
tout petit j'ai la chance d'être né au
cap d'agde d'un sud lier un ancien port
grec
donc en fait déconstruit bagne un peu
loin dans la mer on peut vite voir des
anciennes amphores etc
et c'est vrai que mon père dès fois on
ramenait à la maison donc je trouve ça
toujours été
enfin depuis petit j'ai grandi avec ça
un peu
jade elle a grandi avec la peinture et
c'est dans cette église du 19e siècle
qu'elle a trouvé son bonheur
d'immenses fresques à restaurer du pain
béni pour cette étudiante en histoire de
l'art qui veut faire de la restauration
son métier en fait très très longtemps
je pratique la peinture et je voulais
absolument un métier qui sont en
relation avec cette pratique est
pourtant en fait la restauration de
cette terre moyens d'avoir tout ce que
j'aime dans un seul métier donc pouvoir
admirer des peintures d'avoir son côté
pratique et aussi d'avoir une histoire
dollars je suis passionnée et aussi le
côté scientifique fait ça rassemble tout
ce que j'aime dans une seule discipline
les bénévoles sont encadrés par des
professionnels des conseils avisés pour
progresser rapidement
c'est qu'en fait tu calcules lappartient
dollars venant ici pour apprendre le
métier comment ça se passe
tous ne se donnent des pensées bas tout
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui je ne savais
pas ya deux semaines et j'ai appris une
chose
[Musique]
samedi jour maintenant je sais restaurer
un mur je poussais c'est dingue moi je
savais qui suit pas très manuelle mais
là on nous a appris avec l'aide de paul
il donc à la pièce de pierre de le
démolir un mur de garder les bonnes
pierre ce qui n'est pas évident si les
remonter quelle pierre à la bonne place
et de voir qu'on a besoin de l'aide de
toute une équipe
c'est bon ici ce sont aussi des
relations qui se construisent
abbas tente de bâtir son avenir dans ce
pays encore nouveau pour lui sur ce
chantier
c'est une aventure humaine qui commence
c'est bon ça les gens m'ont bien
accueilli
ils ont un grand coeur c'est une bonne
chose pour moi d'être ici c'est un vrai
travail d'équipé et j'aimerais vraiment
revenir c'est beaucoup trop sombre
vraiment oui c'est beaucoup trop foncé
sur chaque site
la restauration sait-on sur plusieurs
années des travaux qui serait impossible
sans l'aide des bénévoles car l'état ne
peut pas à lui seul gérer tout le
patrimoine dont nous avons hérité jade
se sont donc investi d'une mission
mais peut être moins de ces la trace du
temps d'un pays en fait d'accuser les
traces des hommes avant et du coup ça et
en important qu'on puisse la garder dans
le temps pour nous une génération future
c'est ça la finalité de la restauration
du pouvoir l'a donné à novembre
prochaine génération
comme jade abbas et alexandra ils sont
chaque année des centaines en france a
consacré de leur temps pour sauvegarder
notre patrimoine
un enrichissement culturel tant pour ses
bénévoles que pour toutes les
générations qui profiteront un jour de
ses monuments